hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime opera and today i will be breaking
down one of the most
impactful series of events in the boku
no hero manga
including the likely collapse of the
entire hero society
as we know it the return of some of the
most powerful villains
in the series as major threats for the
heroes
the serious and in some cases permanent
injuries that many of our favorite
characters have sustained
during this epic war arc and the
potentially tragic
fate of deku in the aftermath of this
terrible war there is a lot to talk
about this is some
heavy stuff so let's get into it
if you enjoy our boku no hero videos and
you want us to keep it going please
leave that like it only takes a second
but it really helps
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications i often get people
telling me that they watch my videos a
lot but they forgot to subscribe or in
some cases they subscribed but they
never see the notifications
so the best thing you can do to avoid
missing major videos in the future
is to hit that notification bell and
then select that option that says
all finally this video will contain boku
no hero manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the previous chapter we
witnessed an
incredibly massive twist all for one's
long-awaited prison break from tartarus
and
this latest installment of the story
really clarifies
everything that just happened and the
serious consequences of
everything that happened so no a bunch
of heroes didn't just show up in the
last moment and stop
the villains from escaping this is real
and in fact the situation is even worse
than we thought
but let's go in order the new chapter
starts off with a flashback
after some petty squabbles about money
between skeptic and some members of the
league of villains including twice
we get to see just how useful twice had
been for the paranormal liberation
front around the same time as the raid
on jakku hospital
reed destro had been invited to the
offices of the hero public safety
commission
under false pretenses it looks like the
heroes were trying to neutralize him
separately from the other villains but
in his dark hulk mode
redestro managed to take out a bunch of
the heroes and he seems to have taken
out the public safety commission
president herself i'm not sure whether
she is dead or just severely injured
but she definitely looks like she is in
bad shape
if she is actually dead then that is
another major blow for the hero society
as a whole
and the collapse of the hero society as
we know it really seems to be a major
theme of this chapter reed destro
proclaims that what he strives for
is peace without order which he believes
is genuine freedom he advises the
commission members to liberate
themselves
before he disintegrates into dark sludge
revealing that this redestro was just a
twice clone
if free destro had gone to the meeting
in person it would have been much more
difficult for him to escape
but thanks to twice he was able to just
send a clone while he himself
remained in the hideout we then jumped
to six
hours after the tartarus prison break it
is revealed that
along with tartarus a bunch of other
prisons across japan were also attacked
on that same night and many villains
from these
other prisons also managed to escape
into the night
this was a brilliant move by all for one
who still appears to be controlling
shigeraki's body
even though he has already managed to
rescue his original body from tartarus
by orchestrating six other prison breaks
along with the tartarus prison break
all for one has made the job of the
heroes that much harder
and it will now be almost impossible for
the heroes to track him
down the heroes now have to track down
all of these many criminals who escaped
from like
seven different prisons and we know that
the heroes are already short on manpower
because of the two massive raids
that just took place and the many
casualties that the heroes have suffered
as a result of these raids
i mean how are the heroes supposed to
track down all for one and the league of
villains
when chaos is breaking out in the
streets escaped criminals are running
freely
all over japan and the country is still
only just beginning to recover from all
the
carnage that this war arc has created
all for one
inside of shiguraki's body then asks
spinner dobby and skeptic
to watch over him while he rests
shigaraki's body needs to rest for quite
some time
in order to be perfected however spinner
expresses concern
about this current situation he asks
this person
inside of shigaraki's body who he
actually is
in this moment after all spinner chose
to follow
tomura not all for one inside of
tomorrow's body
but all for one tells him that he has
the utmost respect for tomuna's wishes
and once tomuna's body is fully healed
then both of their desires
will be achieved but at this point we
have to be very skeptical about all for
one's claims that he is just trying to
fulfill
tomorrow's true desires after all we
already know that internally shigaraki
has been trying to get overwhelmed to
give him back his body but all for one
has refused
to do so also all for one inside of
shigaraki
is already saying things like watch over
me
while i rest so it's almost as if he is
already looking at this body
as his own it is possible that all for
one never plans to give shigaraki's body
back to him
and that he is just marinating the
league of villains so that they would
eventually come to accept that this
new shigaraki all for one inside of
shigaraki
is their true boss i'm also wondering
what all for one is planning to do with
his original body at this point
using his original body he appears to
have forced an employee of the prison to
help him escape
using an emergency aircraft but where is
that aircraft going and what is the
original offer one about to do
a lot of what happens next will likely
depend on the answer to that question
the chapter then jumps to two days later
as bakugo finally regains consciousness
at the central hospital as we know
bakugou sustained severe injuries during
the battle of jakku
including a hole in his stomach he was
in critical condition and fighting for
his life
but thankfully he managed to pull
through he is wondering what happened to
the others including deku todoroki
endeavor aizawa and so on and by the
looks on sero and sato's faces
we know that the news isn't all good
and of course toru's face is the most
expressive of all
as usual gran torino is also inside the
hospital
but he appears to be recovering it seems
that both he
and isabel would have died if they had
waited even a moment
longer to get medical attention we then
see our boy izawa
and unfortunately he has some permanent
injuries he lost his right leg as we
know
and his right eye is injured as well
i'm not sure if his eye is just injured
or if it has been lost
but clearly these are life-changing
injuries for izawa
maybe someone will uncover a quirk that
can completely heal his leg like for
example
airy but at this point we don't know
that for sure
and it's not just about the physical
injuries either
emotionally isawa and president mike
have both been deeply affected by the
passing of
midnight in fact when present mike
brings her up
isil tells him to just change the
subject and tell him how his students
are doing i have to say that i feel
really bad for izawa
he tried his best he was brave and
determined
but he wasn't able to keep shigaraki
quirkless for long enough to defeat him
isa was suffered serious injuries during
the battle and i am sure that he will
blame himself for not doing even more to
protect his fellow heroes
and his students isawa has suffered
greatly
both physically and emotionally and
after everything that happened
he will never be the same again shoto
todoroki is also injured but he is
recovering and his life is not
in danger however he does appear to have
some severe burns from dobby's flames
and he also can't speak right now
because his throat has been scorched
to be fair though todoroki was never a
big talker anyway
so i think he'll be fine meanwhile
crowds of reporters are already
gathering outside of the hospital
and most of them are interested in
endeavor that makes sense of course
because he is the number one
pro hero and dobby just aired all of his
dirty laundry
out for all of japan to hear and that is
exactly what the reporters are
interested in they want to know
endeavour's relationship to dobby
and they want to know how he will
explain all of these accusations that
dobby has leveled against him
from what we can see endeavor is still
in intensive care
so it doesn't look like he'll be
addressing the reporters anytime soon
and
as he takes all of this in shoto decides
that he must be the one
to take dobby down endeavour cannot do
it
and since dobby's flames are even more
powerful than endeavors because they are
fueled by hatred
someone has to put a stop to his rampage
before he does
even more damage to innocent people and
after all
who can understand dobby's feelings for
endeavour better than shoto himself
shoto went through a similar period of
hatred for endeavor
and he understands dobby's frustrations
but while shoto was able to overcome his
hatred and become a better person
dabi allowed his hatred to consume him
completely
now dobby is a danger both to himself
and to others
and shoto feels responsible for stopping
his brother
i totally understand where shoto is
coming from but this won't be an easy
task
dobby is both extremely powerful and
obsessively committed to his mission
so stopping him will be a major
challenge we then see shoto's other
brother and sister coming to visit him
in the hospital
and someone else appears to be behind
them and that other person is most
likely shoto's mother
ray todoroki this is a pretty big deal
because rey was in a psychiatric
hospital for a long time so the fact
that she is
out is no small thing we know that rey
also saw dobby's tape so this will be an
impactful reunion
she might have some ideas about how to
reach out to dobby
and she might actually reveal the full
truth about dobby
in the coming chapters we still don't
know why
exactly dobby hates his father so much
we didn't see how exactly he ended up in
that
fire so i'm very interested to find out
the rest of the story
the chapter ends with bakugo freaking
out after he learns that
deku is the only one of the students who
still hasn't shown
any signs of waking up the final page
shows a concerned
almighty sitting next to an unconscious
deku
and that is how this powerful and
important chapter
ends and make no mistake this chapter
will have
massive consequences for the entire
story the heroes
the students and the hero society as a
whole now have some permanent
and serious scars as a result of what
happened
so many are injured izawa lost his leg
and possibly his eye
and deku is not showing any signs of
waking up
and while all of this is happening all
for one and many other major villains
from seven different prisons
just broke free and are out on the loose
and who
knows what all of these overpowered
villains are going to do
next the big question now is whether
deku is seriously injured
or whether he is just recovering from
that epic battle
also is he about to undergo some
internal self-development while he's
unconscious
since this could be a perfect time for
the former users of one for all to make
contact with him yet again or is deku's
claim from the first
chapter that this is the story of how he
became the greatest hero
just a dream that he had after falling
into a coma
during this arc i'm only joking about
that last one at least i hope so
definitely let me know what you guys
thought about this crazy chapter and
what do you think is going to happen
next leave your feedback down in the
comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more don't forget to leave that
like it only takes a second but it helps
a lot and of course if you're new or you
haven't subscribed yet click that red
button to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
who make videos like this one possible
special thanks to alpha sigma disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all
other clans including ingrata the world
acquired respect pate heffa dr cortman
ruthie and yx emperor otaku spidey life
canal
baked buddhist and tungsten tarcus
finally thank you to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel crews anatoly
kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
font rather indiora
alicia ochter bonnie parks hinokami and
water the red-haired raven florian
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games deadly saint matthew cruz anthony
schreiber hijinks and mr waffles 247
if you feel that our videos provide
value for you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you